earlier this year i met physics
professor dr
david wright i love him he had become a
viral sensation for his crazy cool
classroom experiments
here he is teaching me in my panel
newton's first law of motion
called the law of inertia okay are you
seeing people take the tablecloth and
pull it out from underneath the dishes
it's like a magic magic
but it's not magic it's physics physics
i thought inertia was something i could
catch that's like an std
here's a cream you're fine so the law of
the nurses says that objects that
rest stay at rest
unless they're acted upon by some
outside force okay
in this case the outside force is the
tablecloth okay
but it's fairly smooth so the force is
small
and if you pull it quickly
you must pull it quickly because then
you have a small force for a short
period of time
and it it works okay so here's a trick
you've got to take this tablecloth and
don't out and uh take your palms down
otherwise you might pull it like this
that would not work
one at a time now get a little practice
here don't pull it yet okay okay all
right you get step back
far enough so you pull your hands back
like this oh you have room yeah
all right so you know i love some fun
experiments so i asked professor wright
if he'd zoom
in so we can test out some more theories
y'all ready all right
hello oh good to see you it's so good to
see you as well professor wright thank
you so much for joining us again
it's a pleasure to be here it's exciting
to be on
physics on tv yes it is i love your
yellow wall by the way i love
anything yellow sunflowers um so you
you have a new experiment for me right
what what theory are we testing
we're testing buoyancy today okay think
or do things float the problem is
100 000 ton aircraft carrier floats
a penny sinks it's not about the weight
it's about something called
density so density is the mass divided
by the volume so for example
pieces of granite big piece and a little
piece
this one has eight times the mass of
this one weighs eight times as much
also has eight times the volume has the
same
density okay yesterday's all about the
stuff things are made out of
soft things made up things that are more
dense than water are going to sink
okay less dense than water like this
foam ball here
they're going to float and rocks are
going to sink in fact they sink like a
rock
so your tabs are going to give you six
different items to guess
okay so where they float okay
okay thing to keep in mind is this this
is not
easy a lot of physicists will get some
of these wrongs if you miss one or two
i'm
hearing i am fine with looking stupid dr
wright so you're good
all right start with a tomato
a tomato or is it gonna fall i feel like
a tomato is gonna sink
it ready one two three oh it did
oh shoot oh no i can't dude
all right now how about a diet soda
wait is the can closed and the soda's
still in it
going a diet i'm going to say it i'm
going to say it flourish because i've
been at the lake and i've seen things
float
yes
now here's the trick here's their sugar
soda
and the sugar soda sinks to the bottom
oh that's so bad all of that sugar
dissolved in it
and so even though the can is the same
size and there's 12 fluid ounces in both
hands
it's got like 40 grams of sugar
dissolved in it so it's six
wow
yes oh this is going to totally float oh
good
yay yes i was like i've been to an
october festival
thing that's something now
this is a naval orange has been peeled
is it going to sink or is it going to
flow
i'm going to say it's going to sink
because it's all the water it's going to
go into it right and then it's going to
be heavier
all right so let's see
and it does indeed sink to the bottom
you're doing really well
well wait if you would have kept the
peel on would it have floated
ah i just happen to have one with the p
line
okay i was gonna say that's gonna float
isn't it oh interesting
because it peels like a light jacket
it's this piece of the peel and the peel
floats a lot of air mixed in
because it's not very dense at all by
sitting on a pf you know
personal floatation device for the
orange yeah
wow man science is so cool
i love this well thank you so much
professor wright
[Music]